there's too much violence political  violence too much hatred  too much vitriol  too much political violence too much  hatred this is the man who just gave a  speech in front of an infernal red  backdrop calling half the country  fascists whose very existence poses a  threat to our sacred democracy we need  to be completely written out of politics  this is the man whose party has not only  called for but enacted political  violence for years now it's burned half  the country down in 2020. Chuck Schumer  called and said watch out Justice  Gorsuch watch out Justice Kavanaugh  we're coming for you we're going to  unleash the Whirlwind Hillary Clinton  says you can't be civil with your  political opponents Maxine Waters says  you got to push back on Republicans when  you find them in public spaces and tell  them they're not wanted here and then go  to their homes where their children  sleep and yell outside of their windows